have you seen
what jeff bezos is looking like now he's
what does someone call him the other day
the man's beefing up bruv someone called
him the [ __ ] [ __ ] pitbull
i saw that today i think i saw that
today
because he's with the
glasses yeah
mr worldwide shipping
well played bro missed the worldwide
ship look i'm looking at him
yeah fam
if you're the richest man if you're one
of the richest guys in the world why
wouldn't you look like that fam he's
he's
he's he's stocking up he's stocking up
bro he's stocking up these new misses is
he's doing bits for him clearly yeah you
can't have
you you can't be it doesn't matter how
rich you are if your missus is falling
over man like dicaprio yeah
you need to step your dick up he
injected himself that day
he injected himself the testosterone
that evening bro he bought out he bought
a gym that day yeah yeah he bought a gym
and a pharmaceutical company that very
damn yeah yeah yeah went ham because
he's looking he's looking like he wants
to act in a movie at the moment yeah
he's looking good he's looking decent
jeffreys is looking decent for his house
he's like 50 sometimes he's excited
he's looking [ __ ] dude if i had his
kind of cake i'd look unreal oh every
day of the year i look unreal bro
this year my body needs to be a temple
yeah i'm i'm putting it out there this
year my body's going to look the best
ever same i agree same same same i've
got the time stay just the energy i've
got everything i've got everything now
i'm ready bro i've literally yeah i've
got the motivation the time um the
energy
i i'm i'm there bro i say the best has
ever looked it's not obviously he's not
gonna be looking like i was when i was
competing yeah putting fake tan and oil
on myself yeah um but it's gonna look
how a civilian the best a civilian can
look it's how i'm gonna look
i mean wham and lean
come summer
shoulders yeah
i want to work on my legs this year bro
i want to have a base
i'm just lazy at doing the basics
sometimes lazy at doing the basics and
my body's dying
my body's [ __ ] dying and i kind of do
the basics brother it gets on my nerves
so yeah i need to defend myself i need
to start venting for myself now i'm
saying i'm not doing i'm not doing what
i need to be doing today i'm not looking
after myself i'm not looking after me
i'm not looking after myself i've
already had today i've already drank one
of these oh gang and this is like half
done already dang and like
i'm still thirsty so i'm thinking what
have i been doing
oh i've been doing it because i've had a
day where i've popped this in the
morning and the day is like here yeah
i'm thinking how am i surviving
my body's suffering no wonder i'm
rounding for chocolate in the evening i
need something
i need something to get me through the
rest of the day
that's hilarious i want to lose like a
solid best part of 10 kilos because i
know because i haven't been training
i'm gonna put on muscle fast mm-hmm
yeah yeah i'm gonna lift heavy
your boy's going to grow again
titties are going to be bouncing once
again yeah um my teeth are so flat at
the moment my teeth i was holding around
i was scratching myself here yesterday
and i squeezed it and found nothing it
felt like nothing my titties are so flat
it looks like it feels like a shell of
an edamame bean
like you know you've got two other
barbies they're bumpy and you pop them
out it's just flat but it's still got
the shape of it yeah because there was
something that used to be there
misleading people that's what there's
nothing there that's what feels like
that yeah that's what my titties feel
like it's disgusting i hate myself
i hate myself yeah so bro i'm gonna lose
a solid eight to ten kilos over the next
few months
um
your boy's gonna be leaning thick you're
gonna hate it but i'm telling you drink
green tea every morning brother i
believe you bro i might do it yeah trust
me bro you're gonna [ __ ]
james you're gonna [ __ ] but you're just
gonna have to get used to it
drink green tea every morning the weight
would fly off
all right that's why i did
post second lockdown i was drinking
green tea
drinking green tea yeah
to be fair bro that day before we went
on holiday and i came to yours like a
week or two before we went your [ __ ]
gutters
this beating
using a towel or something never caught
them come guys
i looked it i was thinking you're taking
a piss out of me
when did this start when did we agree
that we were look we were going to
tighten up for holes your boy's just
going out there like a tub of melted ice
cream
and you're out here shredding up i was
so i've never been so angry and felt so
betrayed
it's the green tea bro bro that's what
you said to me as well sitting there
looking shiny your skin was shining and
i was like what the [ __ ] and you're like
oh green tea maggie i want to punch you
in your nose since when did we agree on
this